[Music]
[Music]
all right well welcome to another
episode of tactics time my name is
Dennis Larew I'm going to be your
instructor tonight
we have been focusing on basic tactical
ideas using older games and tonight
we're going to focus on something that
suit you definitely has practical value
but definitely has a lot of aesthetic
value if you look up basic mating
patterns or books on basic naming
patterns that this will definitely get
well tonight subjects would definitely
get categorized as a picturesque mate as
opposed to like a common mate on that
being said smothered mate is the topic
of tonight's lecture so we're going to
start with some simple illustrations of
the theme and then we'll look at some
games that contain some cool or pretty
looking some other dates okay the real
tough one here with black you move real
tough real care all right see everyone
here everyone is struggling with it so
I'm just going to say the answer 9f2
mate one of the most probably most
cut-and-dry illustrations of the theme
of tonight's lecture a smothered mate
and we're going to use this simple the
simple illustration kind of build on it
on to understand some of the key
elements to look for when we're trying
to generate any kind of mating attack
but specifically this one um so a few
things that we want to note typically
are that the king is in the corner and
the h2 and ssq squares are typically
going to be poorly defended or
undefended
let's complicate this little a little
more and get a better idea of what I'm
getting in so we have a similar position
here where I added one more piece I for
white put a rook on f1 defending that f2
square which in the original puzzle
black delivered the smothered made on
but I also gave black some extra
firepower we have this nice Queen and
Bishop battery on the dark squares on
the g1 a7 diagonal and before I ask the
audience to find the force matin to here
we're going to stick to the plan and
just point out some of the features in
the position that we're going to be
trying to identify it ahead of time as
we look at some of the games so
depending on which side is depending on
which side is attacking these h2 and
these H&S pawns are Mon H 2 and H 7 F 2
and F 7 respectively on our typical
targets and all types of mating attacks
but especially with the smother theme
you'll see them play large roles and two
other features are the King in the
corner and the poorly defended back rank
so now that that's all pointed out these
are features in the defending position
that you know will kind of Klu the
attacker in that there might there might
be a smothered mate combo in in the
works and then after we solve the puzzle
we'll kind of point out some of the
common themes that the attacker has to
be aware of so help me out here what do
we got shout it out if you see the
answer shout it out can West the baile
teria beautiful okay so as Club favorite
GM can Wed so skillfully pointed out we
start with a common theme that we
see in a lot of these smothered mate
combinations a queen sacrifice a forcing
move note that Y does not legally
allowed to recapture on g1 because of
the bishop protecting the Queen rook
takes g1 legal capture allowing its
pretty-looking smothered mate alright
okay so super simple how fast how fast
are we right here right yeah yep so you
you do know what smothered mate is now
all right
so smothered weight is just a major
livered by the night in which the King
has no flight squares okay as we can see
we've got no flight squares here keep
out of luck is another another some
other mate that comes from an opening
trap out of the Caroline so for those of
you who play the caro-kann if you're not
already familiar with this idea you
might want to take note of this about
here can you find a similar idea anyone
in the room shout it out 96 so similar
idea but we have another Casca motif
we're working its way into this example
that of the king the pawn obviously
cannot recapture because it it stained
by the pawn it's obtained by the Queen
on each you now chess theorists and
historians over time have attributed
names to some of these techniques of
achieving the smothered mate and they're
usually attributed to the first recorded
examples of this type of mate this one
is labeled damiano x' who he also has a
name attached to a few other mating
ideas this is his damiano smothered mate
and this is a white to move here how are
we going to achieve our theme you see it
you
easy have all this gives the youngster
just a chance to work it out here take
your time yeah but in big hint is
they're all going to be the mate the
checkmate the final move is always going
to kind of look the same all right hit
me let's hear it
yep Queen x2 pawn well said
desk you do you did better than most
yeah you did good Queen takes yep
forcing move right wonderful
another smothered me right yeah yeah
somewhere incredulous that I intended on
doing an entire lecture on this one
mating pattern I'm especially one that
you don't see a lot but I think it has a
lot of valuable love there's a lot of
value studying this idea on and all the
simple mating ideas even if we don't see
them in our games they force us to
practice that concrete calculation um so
this one's a little tougher can either
practice your memory your memory if you
read the notation or practice your
calculation here this one's longer this
one's a horse mating like 5 or 7 and
this one they attribute so loose Anna
who also has some endgame ideas that's
repeated to him right so how do you want
to start this off with forcing moves yep
you can shout it out if you want or you
can raise your hand either way yeah
you six
okay so here on this one we're going to
move the pieces but I want you to get
familiar with these themes so if he
comes here what will you play with white
yeah yeah
you made him it's okay yeah made him
right just check me and I'm right there
very good very nice a little bit
prettier too even wants to be a little
more stubborn so he lunge to the corner
okay and here I just want to point out
that we're going to be encountering
Catskill teams that we've already
covered namely the discovered attack and
the idea of the weak back rank all right
so Knight move or Queen go ahead of your
Rufus you kind of seven check King g8
and here is the critical one which yeah
may give you trouble here but as you're
going to see it crop up in the games to
come so I'm sure you'll be shouting it
out confidently but like force main for
okay well let's talk it out so the young
man just yet yes 1986 but you don't
think it's right yeah but so sometimes
we got it we have to break free of the
shackles of dogmatism right where we're
told not to hang pieces and I'd say most
of the time that's a great rule huh a
great rule
um dogma is a useful thing at times but
at times it's a hindrance son and there
are times when yeah now yeah breaking
the rule leads to great rewards at times
again same idea if he moves towards the
center he's going to get made it on f7
right forced into the corner now the
other slightly tricky element but common
and recurring theme and the smothered
smothered mate motif just sacrifice it
gives stuff up
aha
all right
wonderful alright now that we're
familiar with the key themes
let's see them applied in real life
going all the way back so to a yucky
know Greco game you just want me to say
it that way again I promise Jonathan I
was de ya Guinea Greco I think that so
there you go the opponent was so
embarrassed that he refused to allow
allow his name to be recorded no I don't
know what happened sir but uh the
notorious and in he's Allah he's get
he's been all over the world for
hundreds of years
yeah who who is this guy that's my name
tag for the club says and then yeah NN
plays Greco back in 1620 and he didn't
know so that would be funny um so like a
lot of these games and it's always
interesting to note that you know these
moves at least still get played all the
way up to the top level so worth
learning all the ideas that come around
that come out of the movie 45 9 at 396
Bishop c4 leading into one of my comers
favorite lines if Knight f6 is played
but it's not get into the piano
Joko piano
and here the F coupon is undefended is
undefended and as we noted earlier we H
spawns week H 2 and F 2 ponds or age 7
and f7 ponds are the tell-tale signs
that there's a mating attack in there
somewhere you're raising your hand yeah
but here he just castles following
guidelines that we've kind of been
focusing on and trying to keep his
recurring themes in this series which
are rapid development control of the
center and castling early things that we
should always be mindful of no matter
our rating strength or experience
following a typical plan for white in
this position breaking in the center
getting that nice healthy strong pawn
center black contesting and here this
engine evil is roughly equal and even
after the next move it still is but what
would you guys played her with white
pond takes and grandmaster lee answer
yeah no I think that's right that's what
I would play uh but this was hundreds of
years ago half a millennium ago uh so
yeah they didn't know what we know and
he can he overextend to the center and
plays just unjustifiably aggressively
with 'if I've here driving the night to
the very square that he wanted to go to
okay kind of clearly including us in so
now we already have one of our one of
our guys in place for for the attacking
theme of the day all right
wrongly capturing here now he thinks
that black can't recapture which they
disclosed for you guys we know that he
can on who and ident and the audience
can identify why what have I stopped you
at what have I said
after night takes after black moves
Knight takes d4 white recaptures on d4
let him instead of recapturing with the
bishop we just play the Queen age for
immediately
does that look scary for why you think
let's take a look at that yeah so it
should look scary on as the diagram is
illustrating here we have these themes
that were pointed out in the earlier
examples the week h2 and the week f2
Square lighting up here so we want we
want to follow through on our plan of
deflecting the key defender of those
squares which was the Knight f3 we
deflected him by sacrificing our Knight
temporarily so that we can play a move
like Queen h4 which is what you erect
what you are recommending um but it's
worth thinking about because it you went
that you went for all the forcing moves
right all the exchanges but yeah slow
down a little bit and consider yes
sometimes we can bring another attacker
into the mix without having to give up
our nice attacking bishop here
what is lack threatening here should be
obvious but yeah let's just point out
the obvious to kill time for fun queen
f2 and queen h2 all under fire here ah
how would you defend as white if you
were found yourself in the unfortunate
position of defending this with white
pieces what would you play h3 can Weston
and what about a queen queen f2 and
King h1 yeah it's a crazy yeah but you
do survive at least for a moment now not
long but let's just for curiosity's sake
let's take a look at that and see if we
can to identify what what doesn't work
about that um without using the engine
oh you just losing the knight here is
all that's happening so tonight after
the check we brought a second attacker
against d4 so after he moves we can just
scoop up that free bishop at a free
night rather with the bishop probably
one reason why Age 3 doesn't work there
may be something more forcing I'm
missing in there up but one reasonable
defense here is Bishop III and almost
everything else losses and some horrible
and embarrassing way but this should be
three after some crazy defensive moves
you can find yourself with a quality
with white pieces that defending
difficult positions is not the topic of
today's lecture it's about identifying
smothered mate and concretely
calculating three to four move combos
involving that so we're going to skip
past all that and look at the horrible
move that was actually played in the
game again we'll give him a break it was
over five hundred years ago but he
thought it was right to attack the Queen
here Greco being the smart guy that he
was knew that there was a recipe for a
smothered mate in here
without moving the pieces all the way
down to the very to the bitter end what
is it yeah well yeah yeah read out as
many movies as you can before I look
okay okay and then and then made on okay
yep
seems pretty routine and it's easy
pretty easy to spot now right so let's
look at five more games with the same
example same type of C okay so we're
going to speed through the opening a lot
of you in a lot of these because I have
a lot of games here and honestly a lot
of times the opening plays pretty
dubious that as is the case here right
it's that mean getting getting last out
of can watch over there so let's bring
in laughable chat painting it up I would
have to group myself in there with you
sir black might have advantage here um
but white could hold on if you didn't
neglect developments as much as he does
in the game uh and he makes a mistake
comment too many newcomers to the game
beginners and intermediate players all
of us are prone to this kind of just
worrying about holding on to our
material at the extent of developing so
he wants to protect his f5 on when
there's a strong argument for just
letting go over the pond and playing
moves like 93 and the deep on up and
worrying about King safety and getting
your miners out so they can aid you in
that and that objective um black also
object neglect development remember the
engine wanted something like ninety six
right here uh but he plays like you know
I I would probably play like this in a
blitz game definitely you just want to
rip it open it looks scary
but the computer will just say it's
roughly equal here age three defending
yes speak up if you have any questions
over there yes not not too good and you
know that it's the fun and the boring
thing about looking at games from this
era is that it's always there's the play
a suspect on both sides and despite that
fact that one is just one suspicious
player usually just crushing another I'm
not calling Greco suspicious though but
uh some of these moves aren't the
strongest um but here definitely things
are looking good we've got some scary
Queen activity and the White King is
stuck in the center alright so not in
the corner it's in the lecture I
prepared though so we can be guaranteed
that there's a smaller maid idea in
there but let's just spend a little time
thinking about what what creates that
that possibility for him uh we can all
pretty much guess even at this point who
what's the general the general what
how's it going to end how does this
story end mate right yeah and we're
probably going to sack what Ani one
we're probably going to sacrifice a
piece on e1 right which piece do you
think
yep that's that that answer works for me
it's not untrue some piece yeah yeah
vague generalities uh are a great tool
we don't have specific answers okay
so white gets greedy here he takes the
pawn on d5 where he should not have he
should have used that opportunity to
create flight squares develop minor
pieces as we just mentioned but he got
greedy thought that the check might
serve some purpose even though he has no
other pieces in play he doesn't have any
minors develops on the board to aid the
Queen so just a simple Bishop g7 and
ends that and here he makes a critical
blunder right now I see some heads
nodding in the audience yeah
c3 or I I think c3 might maybe the D
pawn you could all you might also be
able to create a fly square with a deep
on but you need loops which is the
German word for air which is a common
chess term describing a flight square or
an escape square for the King so as to
avoid these kind of smothered mate ideas
or corridor maid ideas or anything
involving a restricted King movement and
lack of safety because of that so Knight
f3 allows our somatic idea
I'm going to challenge you guys how do
we how do we force the mate here yeah
yeah yeah often this is you know these
are the moves that are once we're
familiar with the pattern they seem
natural and they're obviously the best
moves to us but to anybody that's not
familiar with these patterns that you
know it looks like you're hanging your
knife until it's spelled out for you why
not not in this case obviously this is
is a really good illustration of double
check um being used and that's why he
can't you can't take the hanging night
obviously and then we sacrifice the
Queen right and the night is forced to
recapture because the night on d3
protects the Queen so this guy has to
take the King can't take and we deliver
our thematics mate on f2
okay so as Ken Wes was pointing out but
Dennis I never seen these in any of my
games um because it how is this even at
applicable it is that it is something
that you we have examples of as recent
as mm and there probably some I'm sure
there are some others that have cropped
up in top-level play since then but we
have a great game a doubt well at the
very least make a puzzle out of but
first we're going to look at some more
accessible games um some more accessible
games from a favorite of mine Paul
Morphy yay all right you like the more
free stuff and I I know I've done the
opera game with you before right we have
we worked on that downstairs once yeah
okay
so typical more freestyle getting ready
to castle
first of all playing a gambit line the
King's gambit also getting ready to
Castle kingside with it's almost routine
development of the knight to f3 in the
Bishop to c4 the Knight f3
a crucial attacking and defensive piece
and the Bishop c4 as we know aiming at
that thematic weak espon I'm going to
skip through some of this because I
think we might be getting pressed for
time eventually all right so a bunch of
crazy moves were made we got a super
complicated position on the board
exchanged a few times on d4 makes the
Queen move creating the threat of
discovered check Knight take c2 would
win the bishop that became or to remain
on g1 he moves to h1 avoiding the
immediate threat but putting them in the
corner a clue that the smothered made
attack is in the cards ok
so as a challenge to the class let's
work this one out together and it should
that you know it may just may be mundane
and simple we've done so many related
but the challenge to you since you've
been so engaged close it comes in but
first we want to open the line for our
queen we want the Queen working on the
day 7 g1 diagonal so we capture the
bishop Queen recaptures now we play your
move yes but not yet yeah you want to
play that but not yet and then here just
as a word of practical advice you have
to take this you will survive if you
take this if you don't you walk into the
discovered check and now
dadless make it make it work make it
work too easy boring okay 93 I have to
double-check right and then check twice
Oh getting better at it
okay I'm in check twice got to move to
the corner the somatic sacrifice the
self smothering and the game-winning
delivery of the smothered mate I hope
you guys enjoyed that at home hope you
guys enjoyed it here next week I don't
know what we're going to cover maybe
another thematic mate maybe some more
fee stuff but we'll definitely be
tactical hit like share subscribe you
guys next week thanks
you
[Music]